un cambio electoral sorprendente en
georgia ya que los dos candidatos
demócratas ganaron sus carreras por el
senado aseguran una mayoría en la cámara
alta para su partido y mejoran
drásticamente el destino de la agenda
del presidente electo joe biden en una
reñida contienda el reconocido
periodista de investigación john o soft
de 33 años superó al republicano david
perdió convirtiéndose en el senador
estadounidense más joven desde 1973 en
es week es con humildad que agradezco a
la gente de georgia por elegirme para
servirle mencionado de eeuu gracias por
la confianza que han depositado en mí
ya sea que estuvieran a mi favor en
contra estaré para ustedes en el senado
de eeuu serviré a toda la gente del
estado o soft quien ha revelado casos de
explotación sexual corrupción y crímenes
de guerra entre otros se une a otro
candidato histórico
raphael warnock quien se convierte en el
primer senador afroamericano del estado
el pastor evangélico de 51 años se
reconoce como heredero y discípulo de
martin luther king también agradeció a
sus seguidores
para ponerme las botas y representar las
preocupaciones de la gente en el senado
de eeuu
warnock que es conocido por su postura
progresista su defensa del aborto el
matrimonio homosexual y los derechos
civiles los resultados suponen una nueva
derrota para el presidente de trump en
sus últimos días en el cargo
los funcionarios republicanos del estado
culpan de las pérdidas a trump y a sus
señalamientos de fraude infundados wow
mientras los republicanos atacaban al
gobernador y a mi jefe los demócratas
tocaban puertas y hacían que la gente
votará las declaraciones que el
presidente sigue haciendo son
incorrectas y socavan la fe en el
proceso electoral en noviembre baiden se
convirtió en el primer candidato
presidencial demócrata en ganar en este
estado tradicionalmente rojo en casi
tres décadas